il y a quelque chose de maudit dans cette terre
notre famille a déménagé vers l'ouest sur une promesse
une promesse qui maintenant avait l'air pourrie
il n'y a plus de place pour les garçons dans cette famille
et personne n'a prévenu mon frère de ce qui
peut arriver
quand on rêve du destin c'est ainsi
qu'alison wells est
entrée dans cette histoire
[Musique]
la voleuse et meurtrière allison wells a
envoyé cinq âmes humaines au paradis si vous
voyez cette femme
ne la confrontez pas d'
accord
quelqu'un va me payer 20 000 pour les
amener au mexique pouvez-vous même imaginer
autant d'argent que
nous devons obtenir tous les agriculteurs et  on
doit chercher
j'ai besoin de sortir d'ici tu me chasses
tu l'
as trouvée n'est-ce pas toi la louve
c'est compliqué tu sais
le pire dans la mort c'est le roi
ici
[Musique]
ou pour n'importe lequel d'entre nous d'ailleurs
je ne serai pas une autre victime de leur vie
peur du cul ouais moi aussi
[Musique]
toi